da berichten wir hierbei klicks und
immer wieder über riesige fortschritte
doch die zivilen raumfahrt steht vor
einem herben rückschlag noch sieben
jahre läuft die finanzierung der
raumstation iss dann wird sie
kontrolliert abstürzen vielleicht wird
ihre mission noch mal etwas verlängert
aber spätestens in elf jahren ist
schluss
die iss ist dann einfach zu alt was
danach in sachen raumfahrt sache sein
wird ist ungewiss die ideen für
nachfolgeprojekte sind mehr als
gigantisch doch sie sind eher um konkret
bisher welche nation künftig sicherlich
weit im weltall vorne mit dabei sein
wird welche projekte realisiert werden
und alles weitere jetzt in klicks und
science fiction herzlich willkommen
nur noch wenige jahre dann wird die
raumstation iss kontrolliert abstürzen
ihre finanzierung läuft noch bis 2024
vier jahre später laufen die
betriebserlaubnis ihrer komponenten aus
europa ab und auch der aufwand die in
die jahre gekommene raumstation zu
warten ist dann einfach viel zu groß
also wird sie wohl am tag ist
größtenteils in der atmosphäre
verglühen
im besten fall werden dabei lediglich
ein paar brocken in den indischen ozean
stürzen und das wird dann wohl das
letzte sein was wir hier auf der erde
von ihr mitbekommen werden für diesen
tag ins gibt es schon jetzt konkrete
ablaufpläne doch was danach in sachen
raumfahrt kommt das ist dagegen mehr als
unklar
die verantwortlichen beim deutschen
zentrum für luft und raumfahrt sind
sich bewusst darüber dass
nachfolgeprojekte für die iss nicht von
heute auf morgen aus dem boden gestampft
werden können und so rechnen dort
niemand damit niemand dass man in drei
jahren fertige projekte präsentieren
könnte denn das müsste der fall sein
würde man einen anschluss projekt
anschieben wollen doch auch wenn das
projekt als es in naher zukunft
abgeschlossen sein wird kann man daraus
etwas mitnehmen erfahrungen und wissen
zum beispiel aus den knapp 20 jahren die
raumfahrt manager für die organisation
und den betrieb ihres babys mittlerweile
zugange sind wenn die verantwortlichen
jetzt über neue kooperationen und
projekte nachdenken wissen sie dass sie
bestimmte dinge tun ließ vermeiden
sollten hieß es zb wachsen derzeit in
ihrer entstehung nicht wirklich als eine
wissenschaft station gedacht sondern
tatsächlich eher eine reine
machtdemonstration von seiten des
westens dementsprechend auch ihr
steckbrief der innenraum so groß wie
ein jumbo jet ihre fläche vergleichbar
mit einem fußballfeld und gigantische
420 tonnen schwer
was erst einmal beeindruckend klingt ist
für ihren eigentlichen zweck eher von
nachteil denn das alles macht sie
unflexibel groß und unfassbar teuer
ihre ganze organisation nahm ordentlich
zeit in anspruch viele dinge wurden zu
bürokratisch angegangen viel zu langsam
und schwerfällig wurden aufgrund der
konflikte zwischen den beteiligten
partnern auf der erde wichtige
entscheidungen getroffen bis experimente
tatsächlich durchgeführt werden
konnten vergingen zum teil sieben und
mehr jahre
auch wenn man sagen muss dass sich diese
starren vorgaben im laufe der zeit etwas
gelockert haben im mai 2018 wird er
beispielsweise der deutsche astronaut
alexander gerst starten die experimente
stehen aktuell noch nicht endgültig
fest fast spontan also bei zukünftigen
projekten wäre sicherlich mehr
flexibilität wünschenswert es
umsetzbar
beispielsweise dadurch dass weniger
partner mit an bord sind im großen und
ganzen ist die zukunft aber noch mehr
als um konkret doch in den köpfen der
raumfahrt manager braucht es die ezb hat
überlegt ihre forschungsmodul columbus
durch die erdumlaufbahn schweben zu
lassen bei bedarf würde es aktiviert
und könnte astronautinnen und
astronauten aufnehmen und die iss
partner haben sich anfang des jahres auf
eckpunkte geeinigt und zwar einer
raumstation in einer umlaufbahn um den
mond 2023 sollen erste logistik flüge
stattfinden und alle würden profitieren
so die wunschvorstellung jeder der
internationalen partner könnte sich bei
einem solchen projekt auf seine stärken
konzentrieren forschungsmodul käme aus
europa und japan eine luftschleuse aus
russland und ein roboterarm aus kanada
die nasa wiederum könnte im vorfeld
ihrer mars-mission erforschen wie das
leben und die arbeit der aktiv im all
ablaufen kann
der schwerpunkt der forschung läge bei
dem angedachten projekt auf dem mond
selbst alltägliche forschung in der
schwerelosigkeit bleibt dann aller
voraussicht nach wohl eher auf der
strecke denn für zwei raumstation ist
einfach kein geld da
denn die finanzierung für die forschung
im niedrigen erdorbit ist nicht zu
unterschätzen so die raumfahrt experten
und expertinnen an dieser stelle treten
private unternehmen jetzt auf die
bildfläche start ups wie aktion
versprechen bemannte raumstation und das
zu geringen kosten der plan ein etwa
neun meter langes module mit eigenem
antrieb soll erst an die iss andocken
später dann aber alleine klarkommen
wenn staatliche raumfahrer dort forschen
wollen ist das möglich allerdings nur
gegen bezahlung noch die miete sei
deutlich geringer als der unterhalt
einer eigenen station aktion übrigens
gegründet von einem langjährigen
manager wieso zudem an weltraumtouristen
und an industrieller forschung geld
verdienen und die ideen
dennoch weiter mittlerweile gibt es auch
einen vertrag darüber dass die firma im
weltall sogar waren produziert mit hilfe
eines 3d druckers und auch andere
privatmenschen haben vision
beispielsweise aufblasbare module die
platzsparend ins all transportiert
werden und erst dort dann aufgeblasen
werden seit 2016 hängt bereits ein
erster prototyp an der iss es geht also
weiter
doch zumindest eine unterbrechung
scheint unvermeidbar anders sieht es
dagegen bei den chinesen aus 2018 wollen
sie tianhe 1 ins all schicken ein 18
meter langes modell als herzstück einer
eigenen raumstation das dann in den
folgejahren um zwei weitere einheiten
ergänzt wird 2022 soll
yang gon drei dann startbereit sein gut
möglich also dass china im jahr 2024
oder spätestens 2028 das einzige land
mit einer raumstation im orbit sein wird
sagen auch expertinnen und experten und
china ist sich darüber bewusst 2016 hat
die volksrepublik einen vertrag mit den
vereinten nationen geschlossen in dem
alle un-staaten ermuntert werden auf der
chinesischen station zu forschen
tatsächlich gibt es jetzt mehrere esa
astronauten und astronautinnen die
chinesisch werden ja vielen dank an
technology review in zusammenarbeit mit
der redaktion dieser wirklich tollen
zeitschrift ist dieses video entstanden
und exklusiv für klicks um zuschauer
habe ich jetzt ein geschenk ihr bekommt
nämlich eine ausgabe gratis wenn er auf
diesen link klickt es lohnt sich kann
ich nur sagen technology review ist
wirklich mega spannend und es gibt auch
gute nachrichten zur raumfahrt neues
zeitalter der raumfahrt eingeleitet
neuer space ex rekord klick drauf hier
wenn es euch interessiert und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran